normalement il y a des bus le dimanche
les Greenland qui passent et là je me
dis avec l'évacuation massive ils vont
avoir mis des gouvernements
supplémentaires un seul je me suis
retrouvé piégé
Cédric bonsoir vous avez 25 ans vous
arrivez de la Nouvelle-Orléans
vous êtes élève ingénieur spécialisé
dans le réchauffement climatique c'est
incroyable quand même c'est un hasard
absolument extraordinaire
disons que j'étais parti quand même dans
cette région du monde
pour voir ce genre de phénomènes mais je
pensais pas vraiment me retrouver à
l'intérieur quoi j'étais parti aux
États-Unis dans le but avant tout pour
apprendre l'anglais ouais voilà vous
êtes partis à moi et demi aux USA
effectivement on pourra prendre
l'anglais vous avez fait la Floride
l'Ohio le Vermont et vous deviez
reprendre votre avion à la
Nouvelle-Orléans vous apprenez qu'on
annonce un cyclone pour le pour le
lendemain vous avez eu peur à ce moment
là
non je connais un peu ce genre de
phénomène et là ils annonçaient vraiment
à ce moment là un Big One et je me suis
dit tout allait organisé le dimanche
matin pour que tout le monde évacue la
ville ou et on attendait que les
policiers décident de l'évacuation donc
moi j'ai vraiment pas paniqué le soir
vous baladez dans les rues
je fais même un tour sur le Mississippi
dans le bateau le soir je vais à
bourbon-suite qui est vraiment la grosse
rue de la Barre City c'était une espèce
de boîte qui joue du hard rock là-bas je
vais rester jusqu'à 2h du matin il
passait des des images du cyclone et
nous et même alors est-ce que vous avez
peur de l'Hurricane tout le monde disait
non et tout ça enfin c'était vraiment
une très bonne ambiance et c'est
incroyable de voir que aucun flic nous
disait bon maintenant il faut évacuer il
faut commencer l'évacuation c'est c'est
ça c'était vers 2h du matin
vers 2h du matin quand je suis sorti il
y avait quand même une atmosphère
d'apocalypse qui apparaissait dans les
bulles et demain matin donc vous êtes
réveillé par un Américain qui vous dit
si tu restes ici tu vas mourir alors ça
franchement ça m'a fait vraiment
paniquer parce qu'il avait vraiment
l'air informé affirmatif il me l'a dit
vraiment dans les yeux il m'a dit ça va
être un cyclone d'une ampleur
catastrophique et ici tu penses sécurité
alors là ce que je fais tout de suite je
pars sans mon sac je laisse mon sac je
vais pas pouvoir un peu l'état des
nouvelles Orléans et quand j'arrive
cannelle Street c'est vraiment la grosse
arcade là-bas je m'aperçois que vraiment
tous les hôtels sont en train d'été
évacués et que il y a vraiment une
pagaille pas possible les magasins qui
devaient ouvrir le dimanche la
Nouvelle-Orléans où sont fermés
barricadés et tout le monde quitte la
ville alors là je repars mon hôtel et
puis je décide de de payer enfin de me
faire rembourser de la nuit suivante et
puis de partir pour en direction donc
pour prendre le bus qui était prévu à la
base prendre le bus pour rejoindre des
amis plus dans le nord de la Louisiane à
Lafayette oui à La Fayette donc à peu
près de voilà et la Nouvelle-Orléans et
là ils annonçaient le cyclone mais
vraiment très peu très peu puissant donc
je me dis je vais être en sécurité et
puis je vais me dire normalement il y a
des bus le dimanche les Greenland qui
passent et là je me dis avec
l'évacuation massive ils vont avoir mis
des gouvernements supplémentaires un
seul je me suis retrouvé piégé et il y a
juste un texte qui s'arrête il me dit
que tu vas aller je dis ben nuit c'est
300 dollars vous savez quand vous êtes
étudiant 300 dollars moi j'ai voyagé aux
États-Unis j'ai trouvé du camping je
dormais dans la voiture je l'ai rarement
à l'hôtel 300 dollars vous réfléchissez
et puis moi je veux dire enfin j'étais
quand même attiré par ce fait climatique
et puis rentrer chez moi en ayant
dépensé 300 dollars sans avoir vu le
phénomène je me dis non mais c'est tout
je vais je vais essayer de trouver un
autre moyen peut-être m'abrité voir le
cyclone mais mabrité dans un endroit sur
alors je fais le tour et c'est là que je
rencontre un homme
un noir
d'une cinquantaine d'années 45 ans qui
me dit bah écoute
viens avec moi je vois que tu es paniqué
tu sais pas où tu as brité vient aussi
pardom avec moi là-bas tu seras en
sécurité il s'appelait comment ça fait
ground d'ailleurs j'espère qu'il est
toujours en vie parce que c'est vraiment
un homme avec qui j'ai vraiment bien
déconné et on a pu passer ce moment
difficile ensemble une amie combien de
temps pour rentrer dans le superome je
suis arrivé à 3h je suis rentré dans le
Superman il devait être 6h30 7h il nous
fouillait à fond de manière à ce qu'il y
ait pas d'armes qui rentre dans le Super
Doom alors ce qui est terrible c'est que
l'ouragan commençait et on était encore
à l'extérieur les autres ils étaient
vraiment ils commencent à avoir peur et
surtout que le vent se commence à
souffler vous savez bon vous savez qu'il
y a un ouragan en force 5 qui arrive sur
la Nouvelle-Orléans vous êtes dehors là
il a failli avoir une émeute c'est pour
ça qu'ils nous ont fait rentrer
quand vous rentrez vous vous filmez en
fait ce que vous voyez normalement
ce jour-là il le sait et le jour du
cyclone lui ce film s'amuse et entre
super dôme comme on va au spectacle
l'esprit léger
moi je suis pour les Hurricane les
ouragans
qu'il a emmené jusqu'ici il lui a
peut-être sauvé la vie
soudain des bruits sourds
Cédric comment en direct
[Musique]
et il pleut à l'intérieur
une partie du toit s'effondre et avec
elle les certitudes et l'insouciance au
même moment voilà ce qui se passe à
l'extérieur le déluge filmé par un
amateur 100 km plus loin
un jour passe puis deux puis trois dans
les allées du super dôme les gens
s'installent par terre et manque de tout
Cédric lui est évacué par les grs
son ami ska est resté là-bas dans un
stade insalubre un homme parmi 30 000
autres depuis plus de nouvelles
les gens commencent à s'énerver dans le
Super down à ce moment-là non ça
commençait à dégénérer on va dire le
mercredi au moment où on est parti mais
sinon au début si vous voulez c'est on
est abrité c'est un peu un spectacle de
voir le l'ouragan qui passe au dessus du
super dôme et il y a pas de problème
particulier on a à peu près de la
nourriture pour tout le monde les ils
ont déjà une donnée une ration en
arrivant quand on est fouillé donc le
premier jour ça se passe sans problème
mais après c'est vrai que les conditions
de sanitaires vous savez quand vous êtes
8000 ou 10000 dans un dans un stade tout
de suite les toilettes sont bouchées il
y a des vins des gros problèmes et les
gens
donc oui à ce moment là c'est c'est
difficile à vivre et vraiment là
un moment le barrage de cède et toute
l'eau du lac Pontchartrain arrive et à
ce moment-là l'eau commence à monter
tout autour du super dome quoi
monter très très lentement et on s'en
est aperçu que le mercredi au moment de
où on évacue du super dôme pour aller
dans un autre endroit en sécurité et
vous vous en sortez finalement parce que
vous vous rapprochez d'un groupe de
filles blanches et les Jedi en tendance
quand même à sauver les blancs avant les
Noirs quoi c'est vrai que on avait la
chance d'avoir un ou deux j.i en
permanence avec nous et il y avait moins
de moyens de téléphoner si on arrivait à
capter sur un téléphone portable le
jeune ou passer le téléphone ils étaient
vraiment super sympa de nous faire ils
ont vraiment provoqué notre évacuation
alors que les Noirs bon ils allaient
vraiment pas vers eux quoi c'était la
seule chose que je reproche c'est que
pourquoi est-ce que s'il savait qu'elle
allait avoir un déluge pourquoi est-ce
qu'ils les ont hébergé dans le Super
dôme au départ alors qu'ils auraient pu
très bien les évacuer de la ville dès le
départ d'ailleurs on apprend encore
qu'il y a des gens qui sont super
d'hommes qui meurent de faim c'est c'est
scandaleux vis-à-vis des États-Unis oui
bien sûr
c'est quelque chose que qui est
inadmissible et moi je trouve que
quand on arrive dans le sud des
États-Unis on joue encore l'empreinte
raciale on voit encore des traces
d'esclavage pour moi c'est ça
les noirs sont vraiment traités
pas comme comme des citoyens normaux des
États-Unis et ça c'est c'est vraiment
très marquant et c'est d'autant plus
marquant quand on est dans cette
aventure et pour être sûr de ne rien
rater de Inna larditube abonnez-vous et
mettez un pouce bleu